there is a business story that's having
major political implications and tons of
people are just misinterpreting the
story totally misunderstanding the story
and the story is that longtime gun
manufacturer Remington has filed for
bankruptcy remington has been around for
a couple hundred years and eight since
1816 they're going to continue to be
around they make the Bushmaster ar-15
style rifle that a lot of people just
love that's the same type of rifle that
was used in the Sandy Hook school
shooting six years ago Remington has
been sued by family members of Sandy
Hook victims they've also had to deal
with defective rifles which we actually
did an interview about with Arthur
Bryant Remington rifles that were
spontaneously firing very very scary
stuff but the confusions here are
twofold number one is the confusion that
Remington is in trouble financially
because of anti-gun propaganda and
confusion number two is that Remington
in filing for bankruptcy is going away
Remington is just not going to make guns
anymore both are false and I want to
break each of these down so first of all
Remington is gonna stay in business yeah
they've been doing poorly as a business
they have about seven hundred million
dollars in debt they are filing chapter
11 bankruptcy but this is a mechanism
that lets them restructure their
business and continue manufacturing and
selling guns this is sort of a financial
transaction that they're involved in
it's not a going-out-of-business thing
where they're gonna just give away all
their ar-15s at a fraction of the retail
cost the other issue and this is the
more interesting one to me is that some
right-wingers sort of the pro-gun
fetishists are looking at this news from
Remington of course misunderstanding the
reality of this bankruptcy filing and
saying look at this the anti-gun left
has been spreading their anti-gun
propaganda and now they have led to the
downfall of just a try a true-blue
american institution in Remington think
about how ridiculous that is first of
all there were record gun sales under
Barack Obama when Democrats actually had
some influence over gun policy we know
that the thing that
sells the most guns is the fear that
someone's gonna take the guns away when
President Obama was president all you
heard from the gun fetishists
was Obama's gonna take your guns you saw
the opposite you saw record gun sales
and then on the other hand under Trump
you've seen the entire industry of gun
manufacturers and gun sales go down
right it's not just Remington it's that
all of a sudden the NRA isn't saying the
Democrat in the White House is going to
take your guns Alex Jones isn't saying
the Democrat on the white hat in the
White House is going to take your guns
they're not scaring you with the
possibility of a Black Muslim Democrat
from Indonesia or whatever the
conspiracy theory was who's going to
take your guns you don't feel as eager
to go out and buy guns but this is not
something that's disproportionately
impacting Remington the entire gun
industry is in trouble
sturm ruger or is it Ruger I never
remember how to pronounce it they've
laid off hundreds of workers Smith and
Wesson has had terrible earnings so this
is a problem specifically for Remington
only because their quality control has
been troubled since they were taken over
by a company called the freedom group
which is a name reminiscent of the
Ministry of Peace in 1984 by George
Orwell it doesn't have to do with
anti-gun propaganda it doesn't have to
do with anti-gun activism if anything
what we've seen is that the anti-gun
propaganda and the anti-gun activism
actually helps us sell more guns
so if only the pro-gun fetishists
understood the story you might see more
reasonable comments from them but I
wouldn't be holding my breath that we're
gonna hear that from them anytime soon
today's program is sponsored in part by
movement I have found that cheap
sunglasses usually look terrible but
whenever I buy expensive pairs I feel
like I'm getting ripped off and I often
end up losing them which is not good
thankfully our friends at movement who
are known to you maybe as the watch guys
I still have my movement watch which
attracts a lot of attention everywhere I
go they are now making quality trendy
sunglasses at really fair prices they're
not plastic they're made from acetate
they have lots of styles to choose from
they've got the classic Styles trendy
round
aviator mirrored polarized for him and
her and all of these start as just $70
and they are now my go-to sunglasses
I've got two pairs I keep one in my car
I keep one next to my keys and wallet at
home for when I go out without the car
and much like with the watch people have
started to say hey where did you get
those sunglasses those look really good
they must be really expensive and I
always am able to say they do look
expensive but they're not and I was
recently as some of you know in Miami
Beach I had my movement sunglasses with
me and it was great they are just the
perfect sunglasses they come with their
own very very sturdy case and best of
all finding the perfect pair is risk
free with free shipping and free returns
which were the calling cards of movement
you can get 15% off today by going to M
VMT comm slash Pakman 15% off with free
shipping and free returns you already
know movement because of their
revolutionising of the watch industry
and you can now check out their
sunglasses at MVM t.com /pa KMA n